-Today is Friday and that's
usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some emails,
and, of course,
I send out thank you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was just --
I was running a bit behind.
I'd like to read some
thank you notes out right now.
James, can I get some thank you
note-writing music, please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
Yeah.
Good stuff.
-Wow, Mr. Energy.
-Hm.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, the Oscars,
for announcing
your nominations this week.
I just feel bad for whoever had
to tell Megan she got snubbed.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, trying to make
Valentine's Day reservations,
for being a slow process
of going from perfect date to
"Is there a hot dog stand
you like??
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoo!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
CEO of Dollar General,
for leaving to become CEO
of Dollar Tree.
[ Laughter ]
Or, as the Verizon guy put it,
"Game respect game."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoo!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, three different
television remotes
on my friend's coffee table...
[ Laughter ]
...for letting me know that this
is going to be a whole thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Which thing I want?
Which one?
Which one is it?
-Oh, let me -- Hold on.
Hold on, let me see.
-No, that's not the right one.
-Give me the other one.
-That's not -- no,
you want the Apple remote.
-Hold on.
Give me that one.
-Which one? This one?
[ Laughter ]
The thin one?
-Wait.
Give me the battery.
Give me the batteries
from that one.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank, you wobbly ceiling fans,
for helping cool me down
while I kind of sleep in fear.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Reverberating ]
[ Imitating blades whirring ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, the price of eggs,
for reaching an all-time high.
[ Laughter ]
Or, as Faberge eggs put it,
"Stay in your lane, girl.
[ Laughter ]
Stay. You know.
[ Cheering ]
I'm the fancy egg.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
49ers mascot Sourdough Sam,
for looking like a nutcracker
whose wife and mistress
just met each other.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
[ Rimshot ]
"You know...?
Wow!"
You and Susie know each other?
[ Laughter ]
What?! That's so funny.
That's so funny."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Fresh laughter ]
Thank you, Dry January,
or, as it's known
on February 1st,
bye, bish.
There you have it, everybody.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Those are our Thank You Notes.